[Music]
welcome back our first guest really a
great man retired uh general keith
kellogg former national security advisor
to vice president pence and president
trump among many other
accolades i could mention
general here's here's my problem you
know i lived through the cold war too i
saw how reagan responded to the soviet
union and
i saw how you folks and the trump
administration responded to all these
threats
i keep hearing fear that we will
escalate if we do things that might
actually result in ukraine stopping
russia
from committing what people now emit are
atrocities and war crimes
and i must tell you i am utterly
perplexed nobody believes we should send
american troops into ukraine nobody's
saying that we should be in control of
some kind of no-fly zone we're sending
javelins we're sending mobile missile
units over there we're sending all kinds
of stuff there but all of a sudden the
line is drawn at
old mig
29s whether people think they're useful
or not
if that's what the ukrainian pilots and
military think would help
what's the problem general
yeah mark thank you it's good to be with
you look
what it comes down to very candidly is
in intestinal fortitude the the ability
to have guts to make a hard decision
instead of bringing your hands in a
negative manner and we're in very
concerned about escalation look the guy
who's escalated is vladimir putin that's
the one who started the war that's the
one who's pushed himself into ukraine
that's one has put the civilian
population at enormous risk he's
actually con he's actually conducting
war crimes just the other day when he
attacked mariupol and the uh the
hospital there with uh maternity wards
that's a that's a war crime and people
need to stand up and say now you've gone
too far that's enough and figure a way
to do it there's a lot of creative ways
for example when you mention the mig-29s
you know when we were in the trump
administration he would have said go
figure it out and we would have there's
a way to do it you can come up all
different kind of creative ways to go
forward but don't be afraid of the other
guy if you're afraid of the other guy
and you're afraid of escalation then
you're probably in the wrong business
being a leader and and we should push
back on him you know he's got his
vulnerabilities we know it we should
continue to apply pressure on him and
eventually he'll break on it i'm
convinced of that he's he you know he's
a very shrewd operator we know that he's
got you know he but he's also
authoritarian he's very direct in his
ways he doesn't bluff and we shouldn't
bluff either and i think we're seeing
that into making a huge mistake
on going against putin you know putin
has made a couple of big mistakes
already though when you look at going
into ukraine the first thing he did as a
mistake was he underestimated ukrainians
he thought they would turn and run you
know when you look at a churchillian
figure in in zielinski president
zielinski when he looked at him and said
you know when you attack you're going to
see our faces not our back and then when
he went when he went to the uh and spoke
in the house of to the house of commons
in england the first foreign leader
that's ever done that he took the words
of churchill basically and reused them
and paraphrased them with ukraine and
and he's willing to stand up and so
should we if a man like that's willing
to stand up under threat and not leave
keeve
then we should stand with him in any way
we possibly can the other thing that
that
putin did which was a huge mistake is he
thought his military was wanted it's not
and i think that has surprised the whole
world when you look at what he has been
unable to do in the number of days he's
had it when you look at general miller
saying he would fall within three days
we're well past that mark he was
standing they're fighting back and he
and he forgot how to fight and and we
should take note of that and say this is
a guy that has a weak military and it is
this is a guy who feels threatened and
we should continue to put pressure on
him and that means military pressure
that means economic pressure like we're
doing sanctions that means diplomatic
pressure as well you know mark here's
the one thing that concerns me right now
because there's always a diplomatic
off-ramp to any conflict you'll notice
that everybody is talking to
president macron of france or olaf
schultz of germany or they're talking to
others around the world they're not
talking to the united states why are
they not talking to the united states
we're sitting on the back and they're
looking on the back
bench sitting watching what's happening
because they don't have any trust and
belief that this president president
biden can pull it off i guarantee you
they'd be talking to president trump i
guarantee you president trump would have
been front and center it's also
interesting to note
that in the last four presidents just
not the last two but when you take boot
when you take biden and when you take
trump and when you take obama and when
you take a bush before him
the only country
that putin did not
the only president that putin did not
take land when he was in office was
trump we didn't look at bush he took
chet went into chechnya when he had
obama and biden as his vice president
then went to ukraine now with biden he's
gone into uh crimea and then we've gone
to into ukraine now and biden never
happened under trump because
very candidly
listening to the phone calls that i i
did and there was 18 of them when i was
with trump he respected strength he
understood that trump was either
irrationally rational or rationally
irrational and he was did not know what
he would do when we killed solomony it
changed the game when we killed baghdadi
it changed the game one example that i
think is important to note with
president trump and how we could react
with putin early on in the
administration
in syria
bashar assad used serial nerve gas
against his own civilians
this was something that president obama
said was a red line not to be crossed
assad crossed it we didn't do anything
when when assad crossed with trump
within days we put over 70 tomahawk land
attack missiles on the air base where
that came from who was on that air base
russians
who was a joint operator of that airbase
russians who supplied the nerve gas
russians we sent the missiles in
president picked up the phone and told
putin don't do it again in the entire
time after that
assad never used chemical weapons
against his own civilians that's how you
operate with putin strength
determination and a fearlessness to act
that is so important that example and
yet we have a pattern with biden which
is the opposite capitulation selling out
and surrender
and our enemies general as you well know
they do psychological profiles of these
presidents and the people around them
and they've looked at his his years in
the senate they looked at his years as
obama's vice president they look at his
years now they see what he's done now
he's arming up the iranians for all
intents and purposes
he says nothing or does nothing about
north korea firing missiles off
including not that far from japan
he's undermining our military with
critical race theory and other stupid
stuff
and uh not funding them properly even
now
and then of course he capitulates to
russia over and over and over again so
they see a pattern in in biden that goes
the wrong way just this i saw pattern in
trump that went the right way hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else